[Musik]
als luca und herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem neuen blog auf einem
kanal meine damen und herren es bereits
heute ich versuche heute 24 stunden lang
mit nur einem euro überleben was hattest
du die scheiße dem ich habe videos aus
amerika gesehen wo leute das mit zehn
dollar gemacht haben mit fünf dollar
gemacht haben doch ich habe mir gedacht
ich mach das ganze mal mit einem euro
ich weiß nicht ob das ganze
funktionieren wird alex finden mit der
heutigen blockhaus meine damen und
herren
die sache ist was wir das natürlich auch
erst mal sagen müssen das ist natürlich
nur auf lebensmittel bezogen weil wenn
das jetzt auch auf kleidung und so
bezogen wäre das ja gar kein t shirt
anziehen und also kriegt man t shirt für
einen euro oder auch beispielsweise
schuhe so also wir beziehen dass nur
wirklich auf essen und trinken das
leider so was dachte ich heute nicht
trinken
schön verteilt des kölner tagen richtig
einkaufen und haben hier noch so
unfassbar viele pizzen wir haben ja
alles mögliche voll das komplette
tiefkühlregal werden hier vorne alles
holprig das alles nicht essen
nicht weil da bin ich jetzt also von
daher ist es relativ egal wir essen.de
vorteil es einfach plastik allerdings
apropos pflanzenfreunde viele leute
haben die kommentare geschrieben du
gerade wolltest doch im letzten block
zeigen was mit dem fleischfressende
pflanzen wortes therapie thema ja also
es seht einfach selbst wenn dieser
großen hier ist einfach wasser
ausgetreten aus diesem blumentopf also
dadurch war einfach beschissen
blumentopf gekauft schau an der stelle
und diese kleine hier stets war die
ganze zeit im wasser genauso wie es auf
dem zettel stand dieser trotzdem hier
schon verwelkt und ok das war schon
vorher allerdings hatte auch hier vorne
gar nicht diese flieger angerührt die
mission fleischfressende pflanzen glaube
ich mehr oder weniger fehlgeschlagen
kenntnis man auch irgendwelche
fleischfressenden pflanzen
venusfliegenfalle seit zehn jahren keine
ahnung was zu hause hat können sie mir
mal gerne tipps und in die kommentare
schreibt das ganze doch noch irgendwie
retten kann
die gesellschaft als ganzes allerdings
würde ich sagen dass ich jetzt erstmal
duschen gehen freunde
das darf ich dann also der klasse keine
nahrung oder so kommen kann man im
internet geschaut und dort steht dass
der günstigste supermann als erster marx
mit denen sage ich mal günstigsten
produkten mit denen ich mich heute beim
tag schlagen kann wenn ich der aldi ist
das heißt da gehen jetzt mal hinter
hättest gedacht freude der nächste aldi
ist tatsächlich zwei kilometer entfernt
in köln die ist einfach nur rewe und
jule ist übrigens auch hier
denn aldi süd ich würde mir endlich
folgen seinen einkaufswagen wollen aber
die hauptsache für einen euro ein
also ich glaube nicht dass ihn brauchen
werden also die gibt's halt direkt so
knäckebrot für 59 cent es gibt hamburger
hot dog brötchen darauf hin was geht ich
verfolge eine wichtige mission muss
heute ein tag man mit 1 euro überleben
ich weiß was das heißt also bisher haben
wir so eine rahmenlose hier am start von
39 cent und wir haben solche baguette
brötchen kosten auch 39 cent allerdings
schauen wir jetzt noch mal bei den
nudeln und gucken wie teuer die sind ich
weiß er hat all die nudeln also hier
sind spaghetti die kosten 39 cent und es
sind glaube ich 500 gramm ja genau hier
500 gramm
deswegen glaube ich die brötchen können
wir zurück packungen kein scheiß 500
gramm nudeln die damit überlegt wie sie
einen tag ohne hunger zu haben das
problem ist jetzt gerade ich dachte okay
wenn die nudeln 30 cent kosten
vielleicht bezahlt ich habe 50 cent für
nur so oder so die kosten einfach zwei
euro fünfzig dieses bei sami churi
irgendwas hier kostet 399 sogar das
heißt ich esse dann wahrscheinlich heute
spaghetti mit rahmsauce 74 cent leute
dass wir gehen wir nach hause und machen
uns ein festmahl und mit uns zusammen
natürlich auch die spaghetti und die
rahmsauce ich weiß immer noch nicht wie
das zusammen überhaupt schmecken soll
wie wir gesehen haben weil die polonaise
zu teuer und alles andere auch teuer
ich habe mich jetzt tatsächlich dazu
entschieden einfach von diesem nudeln
und der rahmen so den ganzen tag über zu
leben
und da ich halt nichts gegessen habe
würde ich sagen koche ich jetzt erstmal
direkt zur spaghetti mit rahmsauce
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt also die nudeln drin vom
aldi und hier ist die rahmenlose drin
also dass hier die hat jetzt meinen
morgen mittag und abendessen sein
soviel zum ordner aus als einfach diesen
nudeln mit diversen die sauce
tatsächlich so eine konsistente
karamellsoße aber ich glaube die wird
nicht ansatzweise so meist schmecken da
ist der treffer hier darf ich nicht
verwenden dann auch erstmal noch was
trinken also die jubeln klebte auf jeden
fall hart aneinander das liegt daran
dass sich auch kein öl oder zeit wieder
etwas verwenden durfte habe ich bin
gespannt
ehrlich gesagt genauso wie jetzt im
markt für zwei euro oder so das ding ist
bei der soße also noch einige stückchen
drin ich meine was will man für 39 cent
und ich glaube 135 sensoren so erwarten
aber leute es schmeckt auf jeden fall
nicht okay also ich hätte wirklich nicht
viel schlimmer vorgestellt
vollkommen okay also ich habe jetzt
gerade schon aufgegessen freund hörte
und julia hat auch mal probiert und
vater sohn der frau selber eine phase da
mitmacht als schnell wir hätten nie
gedacht dass das wirklich so gut
schmecken wird schneller geht die wir
haben sind für menschen über ihr schaut
euch das bei anderen so von der
konsistenz das sieht echt aus wie
sondern nicht sondern der mischung aus
mango sowie und karamell
es ist aber also von allen die
aufgegessen habe meine damen und herren
hier meinen teller die nudeln sind
allerdings noch ein bisschen was drin
die sache ist es ist gerade 14 uhr oder
irgendwas war meine erste mal zeitweilig
bisher heute gehungert habe weil ich
gedacht habe
ein euro und könnte schwierig werden
aber es war echt wird und die sache ist
halt auch nur normale kleine schale
gegessen wir haben halt wirklich noch
mehr als die hälfte von den nudeln übrig
obwohl ich halte allerdings heute 18
stunden überleben muss allerdings muss
ich jetzt erst mal ganz kurz etwas in
bars reparieren und
ist hier in bad malente haben und hält
ihn altherr schwede ist das 40
also hier vorne in der dusche ist die es
dinge wenn man sowieso rüttelt es ab und
das ist ein bisschen blöd ist wegen
kommen wir nun zu lukas handwerks stunde
zunächst einmal holen wir uns natürlich
hier aus dettingen
da habe ich direkt das nächste was sich
reparieren kann der schrank ist gerade
im gehalt zusammengekracht aber das soll
heute nicht das thema sein sondern wir
kümmern uns natürlich um diese dusche
mit diesem handwerks käufer da wir als
eine menge krampf drin erst mal gucken
was mich bei der dusche überhaupt für
den dienst haben eine mistgabel in der
kiste edel mini mac und du bist weg der
mitte passen doch nicht
[Musik]
da handwerker look at the great job also
das ding jetzt heile das jetzt haltet
das ist halt jetzt mich verarschen ich
da vorne mache ich den anderen mal aber
sonst ist die dusche jetzt eigentlich
wieder für die darf ich nicht vergessen
denn jetzt mal erst mal noch einige zeit
vergangen freunde ich habe gerade
wirklich ein bisschen geküsst wie sich
hinaus ich habe schon wieder ein
bisschen hunger
aber das versuche ich gerade noch mehr
oder weniger zu unterdrücken weil nicht
mehr so viele nudeln haben obwohl werden
noch mehr als die hälfte übrig es ist
auch mittlerweile schon wieder 19.05
also eine kleine portion nudeln kann man
auf jeden fall mal wieder essen die
sache ist nur ich muss noch mal kurz im
keller gehen hier unter dem haus weil
ich ein paar sachen unterbringen musste
ich hasse keller so das bällebad ist
jetzt abgebaut hier mehr boden zimmer
sieht das auf jeden fall wieder ein
bisschen lehrer aus so wie man marken
jetzt schon das dunkel draußen das heißt
ich koche ich jetzt mal wieder das
kochen wir dann heute juli in hamburg
führt gegen bielefeld aber wenigstens
kauft jule für mich ich habe dieses
pflanzen projekt können wir echte natur
schmeißen
es tut mir sehr leid geliebte satz kenia
und venus fliegenfalle aber ich glaube
ich bin nicht der mensch der für echte
pflanzen gemacht ist aber ich bin dafür
gemacht ein ganzer tag mit nur einem
euro zu überleben so wie es aussieht
haben wir sogar noch nudeln übrig weil
wenn ihr jetzt hier mal schaut das hier
ist die packung also ich habe 400 gramm
würde ich sagen gegessen und 100 gramm
sie sogar noch übrig ich glaube eine
portion
er hat von circa 100 gramm deswegen habe
ich dann heute locker so vier portionen
nudeln gegessen aber halt verteilt auf
zwei portionen und inzwischen habe ich
halt gehungert also das heißt gehungert
so mein magen bisschen geknüpft ist eine
zweite große mahlzeit jetzt heute
freunde wieder nudeln mit rahmen so sind
ich mal was sonst
jawohl ich hätte nicht gedacht dass in
libyen mit rahmsauce so gut sind aber
auch hier kurzes update freuen der ist
es mittlerweile 23 und 32 also halb
zwölf das heißt 23 einhalb stunden habe
ich heute schon geschafft mit nur 74
cent ich weiß nicht ob es mir natürlich
relativ einfach gemacht habe einfach
eine große packung spaghetti gekauft
einfach eben eine günstige so sind halt
wasser aus dem leitungs haben was hätte
die eventuell anders gemacht werden
vielleicht sogar mit weniger als 74 cent
ausgekommen schrägen kommentare gibt
dort gekocht und sinnlos sehr gut bruder
neil turner ich fand es war cool das
ganze zu testen andere youtuber das auch
gemacht mit 25 euro 10 rauchen in
amerika auch ganz ganz viele die sache
ist nur ist es schon für mich
herausfinden und yahoo hat euch gefallen
das bleibt nächsten blog über morgen
wenn ich eine challenge machen für die
mich der liebe simon will dominiert hat
und zwar ist es eine 1 stunden challenge
und zwar muss ich den ganzen blog
innerhalb von nur einer stunde ab drehen
was soll ich in dieser 1 stunde
eventuelle alles versuchen zu machen
schreibt die kommentare und jetzt bis
ich mich
[Musik]